The idea of an actor fluffing up their resume
with unreal skills might sound like something
out of a sitcom, but plenty of actors have
been caught red-handed.
Here's a fond look back at a few of those
major actors who've lied to get the big part.
It's hard to believe that a hunk like Chris
Hemsworth, who has flexed both his massive
muscles and his funny bone as the Asgardian
God of Thunder Thor in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, would ever have to lie in order
to persuade casting directors to give him
a role.
Just as Hemsworth surprised us with his comedic
timing in Thor: Ragnarok …
"Hang on.
Give it a second.
I swear I'm not even moving.
It's just doing this on its own."
... he shocked fans when he admitted to Radio
Times that he used to lie about his height,
of all things, to get more work.
The 6-foot-3 Aussie admitted,
"There are certainly things I've wanted to
go up for which I've been totally wrong for,
physically.
And I normally lie about my height and say
I'm shorter.
But it can go two ways.
The brief for the audition for Thor said:
must be over 6ft 1in, which I'd never seen
before!"
To score the role of Queen drummer Roger Taylor
in the Bryan Singer-directed biopic Bohemian
Rhapsody, Ben Hardy got caught up in his own
little fantasy.
Hardy really wanted the job, and told Singer
what he called "a big lie" about his drumming
skills in hopes of getting hired for the film.
Having previously collaborated with Singer
for X-Men: Apocalypse, Hardy sent the director
an email inquiring about Bohemian Rhapsody
and asking, quote, "in the nicest way possible"
if Singer thought he could be in the film.
Hardy told People,
"I told [Singer] I could play the drums, which
I couldn't at the time."
Singer asked Hardy to record himself drumming
to a song to show the producers, and Hardy
panicked, but then he got to work.
"Ready Freddy?"
"Let's do it."
"I bought the cheapest drum kit I could find
and found a drum teacher locally and was like,
'Look, here's the deal I need to learn to
play this song as soon as possible, what can
you do?'"
Luckily for Hardy, his lie, and his training,
paid off big time.
It's hardly a secret that Robert Pattinson
has doctored his resume in the past, falsely
claiming that he attended Oxford University
and London's illustrious drama school the
Royal Academy of Dramatic Arts as a way to
score roles after moving to America.
But alongside that deceit, he also lied about
his nationality in order to make himself more
marketable to Hollywood big shots.
As Pattinson confessed to the Daily Mirror,
"I [lied about my education] for years.
But it didn't work when loads of English people
started moving to Los Angeles.
So then I pretended to be American for a bit."
Desperate times call for desperate measures,
and in the case of character actor Todd Lawson
LaTourrette, a difficult situation drove him
to do the unthinkable.
An amputee and self-described war veteran,
LaTourrette built a satisfactory career in
film and on television, using his missing
hand and the trauma of his past to inform
his approach to roles.
"How exactly did you lose it?
Your arm?"
"I was riding shotgun in a Humvee in Kandahar.
We drove right over an IED."
Casting directors liked what they saw and
tapped him for parts in films like The Men
Who Stare at Goats, Beer for My Horses, and
on television series including Longmire, and
the acclaimed Breaking Bad spin-off Better
Call Saul, where he made a blink-and-you'll-miss-it
appearance.
But LaTourrette's career was founded on a
lie.
In November 2018, he revealed that he'd been
dishonest about being a war veteran and that
he didn't lose his hand while serving overseas.
The truth of the matter is arguably even grimmer:
17 years before, LaTourette, experiencing
what he described as a "psychotic episode"
during a time he was off medication meant
to manage his bipolar disorder, severed his
own hand with a saw.
His lie worked, but the guilt was too much
to bear, so LaTourette decided to come clean.
"I was dishonorable.
I'm killing my career by doing this."
"If anybody wants to think this was for personal
edification, that's not the case."
Laurence Fishburne has done it all.
From scoring an Academy Award nomination for
his performance as Ike Turner in What's Love
Got to Do with It to dipping his toes into
the DC Extended Universe and the MCU, Fishburne
is something of a legend.
"WOOOOWEEEEE!"
But he's also a little bit of a liar, too,
as the actor fibbed to director Francis Ford
Coppola so he could star in Apocalypse Now.
In 1976, a then-14-year-old Fishburne told
Coppola that he was actually 16 in efforts
to boost his chances at landing the role of
17-year-old Tyrone "Mr. Clean" Miller.
Coppola bought the lie and cast Fishburne
in the war epic, which was famously fraught
with production issues.
By the time the film finally debuted in theaters
in May of 1979, Fishburne was actually as
old as his character.